President Trump repeated his criticism
of the press during last night's rally
after downplaying a statement by Ivanka
Trump that disagreed with him the
president president tweeted yesterday
quote they asked my daughter Ivanka
whether or not the media is the enemy of
the people she correctly said no it is
the fake news which is the large
percentage of the media that is the
enemy of the people
Paula Reid is at the White House with
the difference of opinion Paula good
morning good morning Ivanka Trump's rare
public disagreement with her father came
about a week after she closed her
personal fashion line and in this
interview she underscored the difficulty
of providing private counsel to your own
father and noted that his response to
the border crisis was a low point for
her I am very vehement Lee against
family separation Ivanka Trump said her
opposition to her father's zero
tolerance immigration policy which led
to more than 2,500 children being taken
from their parents earlier this year as
they trying to cross the southern border
illegally was personal I am a daughter
of an immigrant my mother grew up in
communist Czech Republic but we are a
country of laws as the policy sparked
national controversy the first daughter
remained publicly silent but she
reportedly had lobbied her father to end
it in private very strongly the
president announced the change in June
the enemy the enemy of the people I call
she also disagreed with her father's
take on the press no I do not feel that
the media is the enemy of the people
the president's eldest daughter became
the only senior administration official
to publicly say that she did not share
the president's view press secretary
Sarah Sanders backed mr. Trump on the
issue repeatedly the media resorts to
personal attacks without any content
other than to incite anger it is my
great honor to introduce a leader who
truly believes in the people of this
country it's rare for the first daughter
to publicly contradict her father but
she told Gayle King that she's not shy
about giving him her opinion where
I disagree with my father he knows it
here in Washington a lot of people see
these comments along with the fact that
she closed her fashion brand as an
indication that she's settling in here
and could be here for the long haul
Alex Paula thank you